hello you guys and welcome to another
video today we're going to do a aty or
UL lost for uh Dodge
R the year for this car is going to be
uh
2023 um and the connection that we're
going to
use will be just under the seat under
the let me just try to give you a good
look of it
[Applause]
so these will be the two
connectors that you're going to need to
remove and uh then connect to the 128 so
we're just going to connect that we're
going to be with that or you can use the
star which is right here but both of
them are very
excessive um and they are right under
here so those will be the connections
that you're going to do on the Ram uh
trucks so we're just going to connect it
and be right with you so we took those
two connectors we plugged them into the
connectors and then into the OBD of the
scanner and then we can start with the
tool and again all kyos add the key will
be the
same uh we just going to put the hazard
lights to wake up the
car so when we go to dodge we're going
to get to here um I would like to go to
manual selection just because the tool
sometimes will throw you to the wrong
spot and then we're going to go North
America and by the models we're going to
go to the
ram
DT so we're going to go to the ram
DT and it tells us to put the key if we
have a key but we didn't put anything
on and only have uh the key that we're
going to learn to the
car when we get to here we're just going
to go control
unit and we're going to go uh redem
mobilizer
password and we're going to hit
okay and that thing will take a while
usually and of course make sure you
connected to the
Internet so I will just be with you guys
as soon as uh I get the
password so after a good 5 minutes or so
we got the PIN code right here so we're
just going to take a picture of that so
we have it in our system and then we're
going to hit
okay and now we can go escape we can go
control unit and we're going to go to
the
killas here we're going to go key
learning and then key learning again
again you want to have only one key uh
in the car um all the other Keys should
be far enough so it doesn't
interfere um and now we're just going to
press okay and then we're going to press
yes having this key he put already the
password for us we're just going to hit
okay
okay and then we're going to need to put
the key on the push
button and we're going to press with
that so we're just going to leave it
like that
so we don't release until they going to
tell us to do
so so sometimes it's not going to catch
it in the first uh step um so what I
like to do when it tells us to press
with the corner of the key I just going
to press with my finger and then I'm
going to bring the key close to it so
we're going to try
again and now we're going to press with
our finger and then we're going to bring
the key close to
it and it worked so basically I pushed
with my finger and I put that close
um so it tells us that we can release it
now and now we're going to add another
one so we're just going to take this key
far away and we're going to put the new
one so now having another key but it's
not programmed we're just going to do
that again so again in this case my
trick is you're going to press with one
key uh with one finger and then you're
going to bring the other finger onto it
so I'm pressing with the finger and then
I'm bringing the key close
I can also press the
unlock but again sometimes it's going to
take a
little a little
more so again this time I took the
finger off so this why it got stuck so
we just going to wait for that cycle to
go and we're going to do again
and now we're going to say yes it's a
little bit harder when I have uh holding
the camera for you
guys but I would do it with two hands
usually so I'm taking one hand and then
I'm putting the key right by
it and I hear that going so now it's
going to take tell us to
release and this is how you're going to
do those uh RAM so again I pressed with
one finger and then I brought it close
if you have two hands one hand going to
press it and then the other hand will
just reach it close and you can also
press the unlock in the meantime to get
it uh up and going um so this is how you
can do it and now we have the other key
out we're just going to start the
car and as we can see the car start
right
away um one more thing uh tip um if you
ever wonder what key do you need to use
so any car that will be the 1500 will
use the FCC that starts with the ohd and
the one that that's 2500 and up will use
the gq4 so just keep that in mind um in
what key you want to generate or use the
buttons configuration does not matter
all of them are the same there is two uh
kind of frequency thank you guys for
watching I will see you on the next car
so again one more time the connection uh
for the Dodge Ram um
2020 3 um will be right under here um
and the box is that
box that's missing those two cables
right here in the middle and if you want
you can also use the
star which is the yellow
one on top of it there
so this is about the location of the
security getaway module